you
everyone is cherrymon chess calm and I
just got paired up playing a five okay
so we certainly need to stay ahead on
the clock with this I cannot lean on my
my best friend the increment maybe this
was already a little bit off maybe I
should have questioned that Bishop right
away I'm gonna look to hunt him down
post up here obtain the bishop here
I expect my Knights gonna be challenged
okay mmm okay let's just take and queen
bee three bishop here our first take
here oh I'll go clean b3 pressure here
and then Bishop to g2 so I'm going to
keep this sitting I feel like I've
played this exact position before
okay so Queens off b4 is weakened Knight
a 6 to b4 is probably an idea can black
put pressure on b3 I wonder mm-hmm I
could already consider maybe an e4
strike increasing some pressure on d5
right now let's hit three times defended
twice but two pawns
okay so that's where they're headed I
wonder if King e2 is a good spot let's
just start with this I think King e2
will be a pretty good residence yeah I
really don't see much harm with having
my King go on Castle d2 should be fine a
light square sidestep this bishop so
what about efore right now I think I
kind of like e4 however night c2 hits
this point let's get out of knights e2
with tempo and you know I only after
they played a6 am i moving my rook off
the D file so probably now this move
increase the pressure on d5 seems
sensible I have the bishop pair let's
open it up see how they react to this
pressure on Knight f6 I might hold
ground with first f3 give the night a
kick and only then look to take just
keep some tension in the center I have
to be a little bit careful of Knight b6
c4 could be sensitive I'd really don't
have a he's a king side specific Bishop
so he won't be around to watch over this
sensitive point c4 but I imagine I could
always consider this if Knight b6 is too
much of an issue okay so they are going
for that straightening out my pawn
structure Knight b6 now I have b3 okay I
see
mmm I don't know if I want to just close
it up I think takes so that I have this
advance takes Knight takes b3 g 5
however hmm maybe it is important that I
push yeah I think I need to push let's
let's go for this so ideally I'd like to
have it open up maybe I could try to
show that this pawn is annoying a slight
space advantage hmm maybe f4 to be
careful of my dark squares okay Bishop
here was my idea
what about f4 right now
yeah maybe f4 right now or first
question that night let's question this
Knight maybe 3 to d4 is an idea you
could think about d6 it's a passed pawn
but
d six with maybe night a four night
beasts night B 3 D 6 with night a 4 into
B 6 wow that's very surprising it's not
expecting that I think I do well to
eliminate their strong night on B for
could pivot about on the d5 square with
the rook threatening c5 right now
prepare to double maybe b4 b4 with c5
they can't play a 5 just yet they might
want to challenge my rook actually I'm
hitting e5 as well let's look at the
most direct stuff first
hitting c5 hitting e5 how do they defend
both and they back excuse me time to
develop a new piece with tempo Knight d7
rook double Knight b6 I actually have
that covered so there's no worry there I
have b6 covered who queenside castle I
was not expecting that
hmm c5 c6 action or g5 yeah I think I
really like this move to stop Knight f6
challenging my strong post on d5 if the
knight moves I track him down and this
also paves the way for a Bishop f3 to g4
and that'll be a lights-out move so you
know this this is my idea there wouldn't
be any time to take on h3 Bishop g4 c5
b4 is an idea if the knight moves I have
Bishop to b6 I don't know if I'll be so
quick to take on this square still
playing with the two bishops Bishop here
this pawn is still immune hmm yeah let's
go for this
I could take twice on this square and
then follow up with Bishop g4 if they
take on h3 are they gonna push this pawn
critical moment I think I must have
something here with a basically g4 I
also have a time edge first yeah the
night still can't move I could consider
just taking on e5 I think the big issue
okay so I guess the preparing Knight c5
I could still go with this and look to
still take here Knight c5 them I'm
defending here and hitting the bishop
rook takes I just recapture okay yeah
let's just recapture still on the bishop
they'll get the rook active with check I
just come back to e to stay off there's
something same colors the knight back on
the bishop mmm they're gonna get that
pawn back aren't they huh okay let's get
out of that Knight takes e4 mm-hmm
the bishop moves somewhere other than u7
I take on b6 and then when the exchange
I feel like there should be something
here bishop here is an idea maybe hmm
what about b4 that's a good way to lend
fork Knight c3 let's not do that
hmm
okay suppose Bishop D for drop this pawn
let's make a move
defend g5 okay I get rid of that night
let's go here don't know which piece is
better to take actually I do I take with
the King attack the knight he has to
move and then I have rook to the seventh
and I get to start mopping up these
ponds you know this Knight is out of
play well I mean this is this is a fine
square but yeah maybe I should actually
let's thrown the know actually they're
defending that I got it I got a defend
defend c4 I guess the rook is gonna play
there okay I'm gonna go like this
I want to secure this this dark square
from the king
if they take fire advance pawn okay and
I have the fish up so let's go here I'm
gonna hunt down those ponds I'm gonna
take the B pond but I have the superior
Bishop both sides of the board are still
relevant with having the bishop and in
fact they're gonna be busted on the
clock whoo okay well that was a first
clockwise usually it's the other way
around brought out yeah I was playing
her a little bit faster early on so in
the end it puts some pressure on my
opponent but just to go back this middle
game was interesting I think I played
who was it
maybe mmm some time ago I think the
player a smarter chess on a chest
with something like this maybe where I
had the bishop hair and we had this
structure or I have the doubled be pons
queenless middle game and then the night
arriving on b4
I wonder the computer probably be saying
that I have a slight edge here but I
don't think anything anything
substantial this is certainly where it's
heating up
I find it hard that this is a this is a
good move to take on c4 find it hard to
believe straightening out the pawns but
you know black is playing with a very
clear idea in mind to follow up and then
strike at my pawn trio with e5 and this
grants the minor pieces access to c5
they have good pieces I think a five is
fine this Knights unprotected oh no he's
not unprotected he's in a hole in my
position he's supported well I think the
e5 is fine I think right around here the
capture on d5 yeah I think something
else could be played III think Knight b3
is fine mm-hmm maybe not maybe this pawn
could start to run let's say Knight b3
and I just push not really thinking I
could push through completely
but hmm no actually why even push right
away hmm here's one thing I have to be
concerned about actually with Knight b3
it's the move let's just make a passing
move it's the move c5 within the idea of
94 and there's just no way I could be
better I don't see how I could be better
if I'm trying to work around a knight on
d4 I could remove the knight but then
it's it's either one thing or the other
you work around a knight on d4 or you
have to deal with black having a
connected past pawn
so I'd have to really come up with
something if instead of this capture
they played my beef might be three maybe
I would shoot for D six maybe it's
important I do that and then well you
know what I don't even know where the
bishop goes because I could kick him
away further maybe best is
tough call here and then this is maybe
still an idea with Knight d4 so I can
kid it consider c5 or even Knight a four
hmm interesting position well we'll have
to see what the computer suggests right
around here but I I still think that
this is it's not really going to be the
best beyond that I was gaining some
Tempe to get my pieces mobilized
generating threats doubling rooks
hmm wonder if there was a better way I
could have approached this I didn't see
that they're gonna hunt my EEP on down
and yeah I guess after takes here I'm
gonna be the better side now hmm maybe
hold ground here and not take I'm not
sure yeah I think I'm I'm better off
here
because after Bishop f3 there's no time
for the King to try to come over here to
defend f7 so I have pressure on the
night and if the game continued this
pawn I could hunt down with my king and
mmm probably a good idea to start going
in this direction right now something
like this here and he's going to be a
monster outside passed pawn rook pawn
it's too much work for that night to
hunt him down
okay well we'll have to confirm things
with the stock fish and see where we can
and make some improvements ok stockfish
show us the way where can we make an
improvement here I had mentioned early
on that maybe best was to immediately
give this bishop throw a question to the
bishop right now but ok that's nice seat
3 can't be bad alright I go for this
line to obtain the bishop hair what
about this 97 move I guess on this maybe
there was some fear of like h4 and this
sometimes a concern you know you can't
you can't do this because of Knight
takes bishop and taking away from the
center and giving up the bishop hair is
a big issue for black but I guess on h4
there's D take C and suppose this move
right now there would follow Knight
takes if I'm recapturing then there's
the Queen exchange mmm and well okay
actually this is something I was
overlooking the bishop does have a new
square available sometimes there's this
issue where the bishop can be trapped
you know he tries to go here and there's
f3
after this capture on c4 this this new
square is available on d3 so maybe maybe
that's why this move was played
sometimes this is in fact the best way
to treat a knight in the black position
to challenge it here because hope to
just make a passing move like well
actually this capture suppose captures
right now this is sometimes the issue
that that's why sometimes it's better to
challenge the knight with the F Knight
because after the capture on e5 there's
still two issues here I'm threatening
the knight hand threatening to play h5
hunting down this light
square bishop so by challenging the
knight on e5 with the knight on F at
least when you take here I'm not
recapturing with an attack on the f6
Knight okay
so he had night f2 d7 in the end H takes
Queen b3 likes Queen c7 and now avoiding
the Queen exchange huh okay still
slightly slight pull here King e2 is
fine
c5 I gave no thought to I just went with
that rook c1 okay I play d4 doesn't
really like you for hmm what was what
was the big idea I don't know if I'll be
able to figure it out but what's the big
idea with c5 here suppose they do the
same thing with Bishop e7 oh oh that's
cool
they're looking to trap the knight c5
cutting out the defense of B 491 what
are you doing about the night you're not
defending it the rook is unprotected on
a a ah well that's interesting so a six
and then c5 cutting off the defense here
and apparently I mean given just this
little time for the computer to think
apparently best is b6 immediately taking
action against this trying trying to
defend the knight on b4 basically with
b6 breaking down the structure breaking
through at c5 mm-hmm well that's
something to keep in mind
yeah I didn't and give any thought to
this c5 hmm okay
I think it popped up for a moment night
d1 instead hmm
maybe maybe I would actually prefer this
mouse over c5 immediately this is a much
more committal move when you consider 91
and c5 I like still maintaining some
flexibility here maybe I take maybe I
push huh
now that's interesting okay c5 noted
later up d 1e for even position it likes
the capture on c4 and then the follow-up
of e5 I played d5 I think I must black
starts to get too active after takes
Knight takes if I have one more move
like if I already have b3 in it's a much
different story but the issue I believe
we'll be seeing is that on B 3 g5 will
hit and yes that's the problem I don't
have time to dislodge now this strongly
placed knight on e5 given an additional
move suppose b3 in a pass you move a
five now f4 gets hit the knight has to
go to a not so safe square and these
guys are mobile think about pushing with
e5 computer points on Knight a four but
yeah it's not quite working out if I'm
to take on e5 I don't know if I was
really able to express that while
playing so I went with d5 it likes an
immediate night C 2 into D 4 as an idea
okay Knight c5 f 4 hmm I think I've
thought about f4 with then if this
bishop here I think was an idea I had
yeah they could just take here huh very
complicated
okay I didn't play off for I played
Bishop III it likes night c2 okay this
is where I was pointing out I didn't
think that this was good and the
computers confirming that this is where
there's a pretty significant shift close
to upon advantage now for white with a
takes d5 but a little bit curious about
this move Knight b3 hmm
this is where I was pointing out moves
like d6 Bishop h4 and then maybe Knight
a four it's an idea but hmm f4 okay how
for I there's no time to really have a
strong grip over d4 I was pointing out
before about c5 and then anchoring a
knight on d4 but this comes really quick
with undermining undermining black
center with f4 still likes Knight C 2
here so Knight b3 wouldn't have been
best likes Knight see - okay take I took
what the knight just not best better is
to take with the e pawn it's bringing
him a bit more to life now it's just a
one moment away from pushing and then
he's finally seeing black side of the
board okay this is maybe a when you
consider the two captures you know
there's that rule of thumb take towards
the center unless there's a good reason
not to good reason not to in this case
to take in this direction just you know
generally speaking kind of makes him
that much more difficult it's that much
more difficult to get the light-square
bishop involved if there are two pawns
in his way so this is maybe an instance
where we can shy away from that rule of
thumb and not take towards the center
taking like this having a new square for
the bishop also the night
and we are just one move away from
unmasking our light-square bishop the
unopposed bishop the x-factor bishop
okay I took what the night looking to
just pivot about on the d5 square likes
96 all right so you know I'm seeing that
on the black end there's a great focus
these suggestions are all kind of
pointing at the d4 square we had Knight
c2 eyeing up d4 and now we have Knight
to e6 so hmm I guess black could have
had a better better time if they were
focused on the d4 square looking to take
advantage the weaknesses within my
position and these are the most
sensitive points in my position both d4
and F for both our holes and both
already have the support of this black
pawn okay instead after takes I'm the
preferred side it's still liking to take
with the epon I took with the rook which
isn't bad right there
c5 okay I just doubled play g5 they like
it's likes g5 f4
hmm breaking down the center eliminating
that strong central pawn I just went
about it playing within the structure
Bishop f3 there is no time to take here
because of the cat multiple captures on
this square and then at the end there's
this fork so we had v6 Bishop g4 Knight
c5 like at you
take on c5 where did I do I just took
right away which isn't bad at all
no it likes that better but what's the
idea behind taking the night Bishop
takes oh I have rook d7 not to exchange
I'm just seeing it like oh we're really
going to exchange both sets of rooks and
have the opposite color Bishop ending no
I'm forgetting I could be pivoting about
on d7 with the rook because of the
bishop on g4 ah okay yeah I wasn't
really even seeing that and then c5
eliminating the defender of d7 and then
dropping right in there Bishop takes
Knight suppose
yeah even this oh you could just take on
this square and take the bishop and play
with the two minor pieces versus the
rook okay
didn't see this idea of pivoting on e7 I
just took on e5 which is still good and
now I could actually get away with
taking the Bishop on e7 plus for nearly
man I'm seeing it now you could take the
bishop and if the King plays to d8 you
could play it here the rook on d1 is to
Pitt and also we're ready to pick up the
rook in the corner with 4k 8mm that
would have been nice to see and one
other detail is let's say King here we
can take the knight at the very least
and then after pawn takes there's rook
d7 just defending and we get the rook
next oh that would have been a nice way
to finish so from this point here where
there are these hanging pieces the
bishop the rook I just went with the
most natural recapture and that throws
away the winning advantage King up you
know pretty even now and likes rookie 5f
tix I went with King takes
just because it's attacking the knight
Knight d6 b3 rook there yeah just a
slight fall with f4 and after the rook
exchange Knight b7 e six it likes my
Bishop f3 hmm I guess this final
position okay that's a losing move they
got to play Knight to e6
yeah they what do they do they just took
on be getting a past a pawn but this
will be winning now the final position
just play it out some suppose a5 could
take right away if he continues to run I
just push here I don't have to I don't
need my king to do to defend against the
past Dave Hunt a3 bishop to be one will
be the defense against the pawn and he's
just way too fast the h-bomb
okay Wow interesting game yeah I would
have liked to have seen of course this
capture when things were heating up when
we had multiple hanging pieces right
around here rook takes rook is not
mm-hmm it's not coming with checker
anything so and there are these other
captures to be considering I did look at
this and and I didn't voice it during
the game but I completely discounted it
because after King to d8 I saw what am I
doing with my rook on e7 and how am I
going to be regaining this rook I didn't
see the idea of coming back here to a8
and getting the rook in the corner hmm
okay well interesting game as usual feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comments section below to this video and
I'll catch you in the next one that's
all for now hope you're having a good
day
take care bye
you